- [Voiceover] Hi, Dr. Kutz.
- [Voiceover] Hello,
David. How are you doing?
- [Voiceover] I'm doing
well. I'm excited to learn
about this thing we call "the Cold War."
What is a "cold war" and what makes it
different than a "hot war"?
- [Voiceover] So, a cold
war, and in this case
it's really,
it might be a term that we could debate.
is a war where the two major combatants
never actually fire bullets at each other
or drop bombs on each other.
So never in the course
of the Cold War did the
US ever meet the ground
troops with the USSR.
- [Voiceover] But people
still died in combat.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So the Cold
War is kind of fought
through proxy wars. And
these are wars that are
taking place in other
nations, developing nations
of the world where the US
is supporting one side,
generally the pro-capitalist side,
and the Soviet Union is supporting
the other side, a communist side.
So this is the case in the Korean War
in the 1950s, and then definitely
the case in the Vietnam War in the 1960s.
- [Voiceover] So the US and
the USSR aren't fighting
directly but they're kind of
betting on boxing matches,
betting on different fighters
in the same boxing match.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, but
they're not just betting,
they're also putting money and arms
where their mouth is.
- [Voiceover] So now if
there are two different
fighters in the ring, the US is given
the capitalist fighter...
feeding him...
- [Voiceover] So you've
got the capitalist fighter
in one corner and he's
sweaty and he's beaten,
but the US is behind
him with a towel and one
of those water buckets,
splashing water in his face,
like "Get in this fight! Get in there!'
- [Voiceover] Right. And if necessary,
tying up his boxing gloves,
maybe giving him a new pair of shoes.
- [Voiceover] Sure.
- [Voiceover] Doing whatever they can...
- [Voiceover] Paying his rent...
- [Voiceover] Right. Doing everything
that they can... - [Voiceover]
Buying him meals, probably,
like at the Marshall Plan.
- [Voiceover] Exactly!
- [Voiceover] Okay, so
tell me about these two
combatants. In this corner...
- [Voiceover] Laughs.
- [Voiceover] Wearing a suit...
- [Voiceover] (laughs) Is Harry Truman.
And Harry Truman is the President of the
United States, starting in 1945.
He was Vice President
to Franklin Roosevelt,
who had been the US's
president since 1932,
and who tragically died in 1945.
So Truman is really in charge of ending
World War II for the
United States and also
kind of setting up post-war plans.
- [Voiceover] So he
prosecutes the end of the war.
He makes the decision
to drop the atom bomb
on Nagasaki and Hiroshima,
and he ends the war in both theaters.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] And...
- [Voiceover] And in the
other corner, wearing a
very fine mustache...
- [Voiceover] (laughs) Is Joseph Stalin.
And he's the Soviet premier.
He's been in charge since the 1920s.
And for him, I would
say the most important
thing that Stalin wanted
after World War II
was security, shall we say.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] So if you
remember your history,
in World War I
Germany invaded Russia.
In World War II
- [Voiceover] Oh, I'm seeing a pattern.
- [Voiceover] And if there's
anything that Stalin wants
in the post-1945 era,
it is not to be invaded
by Germany anymore.
- [Voiceover] Sure.
- [Voiceover] So he is
very anxious to make sure
that the world is safe for communism.
He thinks that
the best way to make sure that
Russians can continue
the experiments and the
revolution of communism
is to have a buffer zone,
shall we say, between Russia
and the rest of Europe.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] And if he does
that by kind of shoring up
some puppet governments,
in what we now call the
Eastern Block,
these nations that had been
taken over by Hitler
and then when the Soviet Union joined the
war on the side of the Allies,
then were retaken over
by Russia as they fought Hitler back.
- [Voiceover] Okay. So a lot
of those central European
countries like Hungary, and
Lithuania, and the former
Czechoslovakia, and the former Yugoslavia.
- [Voiceover] And he had
the advantage of having
boots on the ground
there because he'd beaten
back Hitler's invasion,
eventually White Russian
troops were fighting
against Hitler, and American
troops who were fighting against Hitler.
You know, they meet in Berlin
at the fall of Hitler,
and kind of shake hands in Berlin.
But the advantage that Russia had was
that they've got a lot more people here.
They've got most of Europe now,
at least east of Berlin,
has Soviet troops on the ground.
- [Voiceover] Sure. So
you've been telling me
that the Soviet Union did yeoman's work
in containing and basically
prosecuting the entire
Eastern Front during World War II.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, and
the Soviet Union actually
lost 20 million people
during World War II.
That's just a ludicrous number.
They lost more than anyone except
for China and Germany.
So they feel like they have a real stake
in the outcome of World War II.
- [Voiceover] So, at the
end of this, what is the
situation in the USSR?
Like they've conquered
all of this territory
but are they strong enough
economically to hold all of it
and feed everyone?
- [Voiceover] No, not really.
In fact, most of Europe
is in pretty dire straits
if you think about it.
All of World War II was
really kind of fought,
right, in Europe...
- [Voiceover] Right in
the European bread basket.
- [Voiceover] And so
there is serious economic
trouble in the aftermath of World War II.
People don't have enough to eat.
They certainly don't have any cash,
and they don't have any fuel,
which is very worrisome
in 1946 because of the terrible winter.
So people are cold and they are hungry.
And when people are
cold and hungry there is
a lot of fuel for a
possible revolution, right?.
Even in the 1930s, in the
United States, there's
a lot of different
political ideas that come up
during the Great Depression.
Because when your political
system isn't working well,
you consider other kinds
of political systems.
- [Voiceover] So the United
States is worried that,
because of the cold winter
of 1946, and scarcity
across western Europe,
this blue part of the
map will turn much redder.
- [Voiceover] Right. So for
the United States, they're
worried that communism
is kind of the child
of hunger and poverty.
And they're afraid that
because Stalin has so much
territory in Europe, that
he is really well poised
to become "Hitler, part two."
- [Voiceover] Okay. And
that is a sequel the
United States does not want to see.
- [Voiceover] No. Absolutely not.
And if they really learned
anything from World War II,
it's that appeasement doesn't work, right?
During the 1930s, many people in the West,
the prime minister of
England, Neville Chamberlain,
kind of felt like they
didn't want to go back to war
because World War I is still very much on
people's minds during the 1930s.
And so they figured,
let's not confront Hitler
head on because we're not
up for that right now.
We're also in the middle
of worldwide depression.
And that helped nothing
because it just meant that
Hitler could gain a whole lot of territory
and World War II was
much worse than it might
have been if they hadn't
gone after Hitler earlier.
- [Voiceover] And stopped the Anschluss.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [Voiceover] If you stop
the Anschluss, you stop
the "onschlaught."
- [Voiceover] (laughs) Exactly.
So they're really trying
to say, all right, Stalin, if
he wants to, could probably
just run his way through
the rest of Europe, right,
with very little resistance,
because the only nation in the world
that has the military and economic
power to stop the Soviet
Union is the United States.
- [Voiceover] Because
their factories and fields
were not bombed to cinders during the
European theater.
- [Voiceover] Right. So if they wanna stop
"Hitler, part two, the Stalin years,"
then they're going to have to really
stand up for capitalism
and also for the kind
of material comforts and
democratic, what we
call, self-determination.
This is one of the most
important ideas to come
out of the alliance
between the United States
and Britain, which is that
the citizens of a region
should have the right to decide their own
form of government.
- [Voiceover] And they think
of the Soviets as being
totalitarians. And that's
not a wrong assessment
because there is a very
strong totalitarian control
coming out of Moscow and the Soviet Union.
So they say, If we're going to keep Europe
from turning all red, all communist,
then we're going to need
to kind of shore up Europe.
They think of communism
as kind of being a little
bit like a flood, shall we say,
that you gotta, you gotta put sandbags
around the edges of communism.
Otherwise, it's gonna leak out.
- [Voiceover] So is the
United States and their allies
also interested in
creating their own kind of
light blue buffer zone, also
next to the Eastern Block?
Or are they interested in...
Is this when we get into
the creation of NATO?
- [Voiceover] NATO really comes out of an
understanding that World
War II has not created peace
and so the US is going to have to
forego their more than a century-long
commitment to being isolationist
and take a stronger role in the world.
- [Voiceover] So, okay,
for the folks at home, what
does NATO stand for? North
Atlantic Treaty Organization?
- [Voiceover] North Atlantic
Treaty Organization.
And this is a defensive alliance
between, at first, 12 nations,
which say that an attack on one
will be treated as an attack on all.
- [Voiceover] Gotcha! Well,
that sounds like they're
maneuvering their boxers into position
and rubbing the shoulders
and getting them ready.
- [Voiceover] Yes. Very much so.
And I think one of the tragedies
of the post-war era
is that maybe things didn't
have to be like this?
Right after the US and the USSR had worked
together to defeat Hitler,
it might have possible for them
to coexist peacefully?
But I think they both had
the idea that the other
economic system, and we're talking about
communism and capitalism,
were just kind of
riddled with internal
inconsistencies and that
eventually the world
would be all capitalist
or all communist.
And they were going to have to really
marshal all of their resources behind
their chosen boxer or
they were gonna lose.
- [Voiceover] Sounds
like a fight that's gonna
take a long time.
- [Voiceover] And it did.
- [Voiceover] End round one!